[Music]
on this Wednesday night the world
prepares as the kovat 19 virus spreads
I think there's pretty good agreement
that we are heading towards a pandemic
how ready is Canada how ill-prepared is
the US and the confusion for travelers
Plus what do the warnings this could
disrupt our lives really mean I'll speak
with an infectious disease specialist
tempers flare in Tyendinaga fired up
protesters find new ways to try to
disrupt rail service why they weren't
arrested what climate change will mean
for Alberta a new report on how the
province needs to adapt
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what could be a tipping
point in the spread of kovat 19 the
World Health Organization now says there
are more new cases of the corona virus
outside China than inside that country
there are cases in every continent
except Antarctica now with attention
shifting from Asia to Europe countries
there are struggling to come up with a
unified response and with so many
unknowns there's confusion about whether
to travel and what to avoid here's what
we know about where the virus is
spreading outside Asia right now the
biggest outbreaks are in Italy and Iran
and from there the infection is
spreading kind of like a web across the
world people who had been in Italy are
now linked to cases in Algeria Austria
Croatia Germany Greece Spain Switzerland
and Brazil and people who had been in
Iran are being linked to new cases in
Bahrain Iraq Kuwait and Oman Canada has
recorded a second case in someone who
traveled from Iran and it's the 12th
confirmed case here at least 46
countries and territories have detected
the virus and dozens of passengers who
were let off the diamond Princess cruise
ship in Japan have now developed
symptoms and a fourth person has died
now another cruise ship is run into
trouble as well 6100 people are on board
the Mara Vilia it's been turned away
from Jamaica and the Cayman Islands
because a crew member has flu-like
symptoms and is now in isolation on
board the cruise ship company says it's
just a case of the flu the ship is on
route to its next port of call in
Cozumel Mexico and in Italy more than
400 people have tested positive for the
virus that's the biggest outbreak
outside Asia crystal gyum ancing has our
top story tonight chemists in Milan are
mixing up batches of hand sanitizer
customers concerned about the new
coronavirus bought up all of the
available stock Italy is the center of a
European outbreak red zones in the north
are being patrolled by members of the
military and police anyone trying to
sneak in or out could be jailed for
three months the Saskatchewan woman is
stuck in Milan waiting
were suspended for following week so
this week and that's basically all we've
heard so far
Iran is another location of particular
concern it's believed there are far more
Cova 19 cases there than Iranian
officials are reporting a special
investigative team from the World Health
Organization will arrive there this
weekend similar teams were deployed to
China and one is working in Italy we
take the virus and the situation very
seriously at the same time we should
also remember that four out of five
patients have mild symptoms and recover
the fact that kovat 19 can be mild in
some could be obscuring the true number
of infected individuals dr. Michael
Gartin says it's likely there are many
more people out there with the virus we
have not stopped anything and I think
that you know the academics the people
like me who are out there looking at the
epidemiology I think there's pretty good
agreement that we are heading towards a
pandemic slowing this spread is critical
but responses are different in each
country in London for example the energy
company Chevron told people to work from
home until test results come back for a
worker with flu-like symptoms the UK has
13 cases South Korea has more than 1000
cases but buses are still rolling after
being disinfected in uneasy times this
driver says it gives them a bit of
comfort crystal commencing Global News
London
preparing for a virus that's new to
humans and that experts still don't
fully understand isn't simple Canada
does have a plan on how to handle
pandemics tonight Michael Couture takes
a look at the mechanisms that are in
place to tackle an outbreak Mike
well Donna as kovat 19 has evolved into
a wider global outbreak so too has the
federal government's approach to it well
the Health Minister says the current
risk in Canada is low Patti hi do is
acknowledging that could change globally
there's a higher likelihood that will
see an outbreak in Canada haidu doesn't
want Canadians to panic but she says it
could be prudent for people to be
prepared just in case it's really about
first of all making sure that you do
have enough supplies if someone in your
family becomes ill if you yourself
become ill that you have what you need
to survive you know for a week or so
without having without going out haidu
says Canada's national microbiology lab
in Winnipeg has a more robust test for
the corona virus than us so in some ways
were better prepared for a possible
outbreak and she added there's a
federally coordinated pandemic plan
that's been in place since 2009 there
are a lot of similarities to how we
would manage this compared to h1n1 dr.
Suzie Hoda says some of the lessons
learned from that outbreak and SARS were
to ensure proper screening and proper
protection for healthcare workers then
there's the plan for people in the
community from things as simple as
frequent hand-washing to a more extreme
step of suggesting people avoid mass
gatherings sometimes schools and other
areas where people are congregating
quite a bit can get closed so we modify
the way that we interact with each other
so we reduce that risk of people
exposing each other
Canada isn't there yet into further calm
fears Ontario's chief medical officer
says we have a distinct advantage
compared to past outbreaks we know the
organism we have a lab test and forcing
for us we have the experience what China
has worked through and we have our
epidemiologists and our experts
informing us what they learned what they
know what we do with this virus
doctors say sharing information
internationally can help mitigate a
global pandemic adding 10 years ago that
level of coordination and collaboration
didn't exist Donna okay Mike look at ER
in Ottawa Thanks in the US president
Trump just addressed the American
response to the virus he's blamed the
media for making it look as bad as
possible today he said he doesn't think
the spread of the virus is inevitable
even though that's what officials from
the American Centers for Disease Control
said yesterday there are 60 confirmed
cases in the u.s. now that number is
likely higher though because few people
have
tested and many test kits were found to
be faulty Jackson Prosecco has been
listening to the president Jackson
what's his message well Donna the
president spent most of his press
conference repeatedly downplaying the
threat of coronavirus suggesting it's
very much the same as the flu even
though it's mortality rate is much much
higher Trump in fact expressed his own
shock at learning about the mortality
rate of the regular flu he bragged that
the u.s. is better prepared than any
country he said all cases of coronavirus
in the US will still be gone that does
not jive with what his own experts have
been saying in recent days they've
proclaimed that it's practically
inevitable that coronavirus will arrive
in larger scale and community
transmission here in the US in the near
future he also said that a vaccine will
be here soon his own experts have said
it's a year to 18 months away bottom
line Donna he's taking issue with the
idea that spread here is inevitable take
a listen to what he said a short time
ago well I don't think it's inevitable I
probably will it possibly will it could
be at a very small level or could be at
a larger level what whatever happens
we're totally prepared we have the best
people in the world Jackson the
president sounding very optimistic not
many people in the US though have been
tested I think it's about 500 that
compares to tens of thousands of people
in countries like South Korea and the
seamy CDC has admitted that some of its
test kits are faulty what's going on
yeah there's a real concern here that no
one has a full picture of the spread of
the virus here in the US or whether
community transmission is already taking
place because of those limits and
testing capacity as you mentioned faulty
kits they've been very narrowly
distributed to only four or five sites
the situation's so dire for some health
authorities that in Hawaii they've asked
to send their samples to Japan for
verification Donna the president has
appointed his vice president Mike Pence
to oversee all these efforts but
suggested that there's no need to ramp
up testing capacity right now all right
Jackson Prosecco in Washington thank you
there's a development tonight in the
rail blockades in this country the wid
so it and hereditary Chiefs say some
progress is being made about the RCMP
presence on their territory in northern
BC
protests though and blockades keep
happening elsewhere today one reached a
potentially dangerous new level a fire
was lit along the tracks and Tyendinaga
Mohawk territory that's not far from the
scene of a major police operation
earlier this week the flaming debris
eventually forced that train to stop
temporarily the Federal Transport
Minister calls what happened extremely
reckless David akin reports a CN Rail
Engineer sounds his horn time and time
again
but protesters remain on the track and
then at the last moment these
self-described Mohawk warriors scurry
for safety some pick up rocks to hurl at
the passing train this dramatic video
was filmed by one of the protesters and
streamed live on the group's Facebook
site now though Ontario Provincial
Police dismantled a separate barricade
at Tyendinaga on Monday these protesters
are at a new site two kilometres away
and when C and Rail put its first trains
through here in nearly three weeks some
protesters threw burning debris on the
tracks to try to stop it this was an
extremely reckless act and something
that not only put in endanger the life
of people who were actually lighting
this fire under a moving train but also
could have been very dangerous for many
other people then later in the day at
another rail crossing nine kilometers
west a car is driven onto the tracks and
set on fire
but the Tyendinaga protesters say they
will not stand down until the RCMP leave
what so it in territory in northern BC
and further east in the Quebec Mohawk
community of Ghana [ __ ] a more blockades
also in support of the wood so it the
the Kenyan government has to come to an
agreement with they were soon to chiefs
that's what it's all about and and
that's what a pressure should be
meanwhile Quebec Premier France while
ago suggested Wednesday that the gonna
walk eight protesters were armed with
ak-47 assault rifles Legault offered no
proof though and Mohawk leaders accused
Legault of inflaming tensions
there's no armaments there's no arms or
anything like that you know but it's
clear that tension continues to build at
many of these flash points across the
country and that tension may not begin
to recede until it what so it and
hereditary Chiefs resolve their
differences with the RCMP Donna okay
David akin in Ottawa Thanks so there was
some optimism earlier today from those
hereditary chiefs about the presence of
the RCMP and there were more talks today
but late today it seemed to fall apart
the chief said only partial concessions
have been made by the federal and
provincial governments they want the
RCMP and coastal gas link off their
territory but she
claim both governments have now pulled
out of talks with cabinet ministers that
it was thought might happen tomorrow
global Sarah MacDonald is in northern BC
and explains a holiday played out signs
of optimism and dialogue Wednesday in
northern BC as with so it a nation's
hereditary Chiefs returned to the table
for another day of talks their
willingness federally to come here is
there and our hope is that today will be
the table we can move forward that this
week have involved former longtime
member of parliament nathan cullen
acting as an intermediary between all
sides involved in a standoff over
pipeline politics arrests on indigenous
lands only adding fuel to the fire of a
national crisis that's quickly veering
off the rails the injunction says that
we were trespassing on cien property as
far as we're concerned CN is trespassing
in our territory this chief of gits and
nation a longtime neighbor and Ally of
the wits so attend one of those detained
on Monday as RCMP moved in to clear a
blockade erected in solidarity with his
hereditary counterparts the coton nation
couldn't very well stand by and let them
take all the heavy lifting but a large
faction of what's so it in people like
bonnie george are banking on the
benefits promised by that lucrative
proposed natural gas pipeline and on
constructive dialogue the ones that are
protesting across canada and downtown
vancouver they have jobs to go back to
and our people don't have jobs many here
welcome the economic opportunity offered
by the multi-billion dollar project
given the greenlight by bad councils and
backed by the provincial and federal
governments we feel like we're being
bullied by people who supposed to be our
leaders but not the traditional leaders
who maintain their conditions must be
met first before any talks with Ottawa
as all eyes remain on with Soda nation
and that's a global Sarah MacDonald
reporting from northern BC late today
word no further talks are planned so it
looks like it is back to square one
coming up what climate change could mean
for Alberta a new report on the impact
on that province is a con
infrastructure and health
a new report on the impact of climate
change on Alberta has just been released
with no fanfare it's written by a
world-renowned climate scientists but
commissioned by the previous NDP
government it warns climate change will
have a profound impact on infrastructure
economy and public health in alberta
heather Eurex west explains in the past
decade Alberta has experienced the
devastating power of extreme weather at
time and again from the 2013 flooding in
High River and Calgary to the 2016 fires
that burned much of Fort McMurray to the
ground climate scientists warned that as
global temperatures increase these kinds
of events will only become more intense
in a warming world wired wildfires which
always happen naturally are burning
greater area floods which always happen
naturally are much more intense with a
lot more rainfall associated with them
Katharine Hayhoe is the climate
scientist behind a new report into
Alberta's climate future among the
report's findings a rapid increase in
the number of days above 30 degrees
Celsius winter warming trends twice the
global average dryer soil conditions
particularly in the southern part of the
province and more rain during the winter
months it also warns Alberta's projected
climate changes will profoundly impact
its natural environment potentially
affecting the provinces agriculture
infrastructure and natural resources as
well as the health and welfare of its
inhabitants the report was commissioned
by Alberta's previous Environment
Minister I think what we need in Alberta
and across the country really is a
better assessment of what is to come so
that we can properly make investments
for climate adaptation the final report
was delivered to the United Conservative
Party government in August but was not
released until earlier this week despite
two separate Freedom of Information
requests made by global news and the
Alberta Federation of Labor someone also
backdated the report to make it appear
as though it was posted in September
burying it behind months of more
recently released reports on the
provincial website it's clear to us that
the Kenney government has made a
concerted effort to bury this report and
I say that because of the all the hoops
that we had to jump through in order to
get our hands on it but the UCP denies
any effort was made
to vary the report pointing out it's now
available for the public to see online
Heather your ex west global news Calgary
ahead just call me Harry
why the sixth in line to the throne is
back in the UK
Peter Nygaard the Winnipeg born man who
built an international fashion company
has stepped down as CEO after sexual
assault allegations emerged the
announcement was made hours after the
FBI and New York City police raided his
Manhattan headquarters Nygaard is under
criminal investigation for sex
trafficking at least ten women filed a
civil suit against him accusing him of
sexual abuse at his estate in the
Bahamas Prince Harry is back in the UK
and he made a special request on his
final round of engagements before he
steps down as a senior royal and he's
made it clear that we are all just to
call him Harry just Harry he was in
Edinburgh launching an eco-friendly
travel firm the Duke of Sussex asked the
host to ask delegates to drop his royal
title Prince Harry or Harry as he wants
to be called will wave goodbye to was
royal duties officially in less than
five weeks preparing for a pandemic next
why one expert says it's too late to
contain the spread of Kovan 19
welcome back we're going to go back to
the new coronavirus now what to make of
its spread and how it could disrupt your
life joining me from Toronto General
Hospital is dr. Isaac bogus she's an
epidemiologist and a specialist in
infectious disease dr. bull gosh first
let's deal with travel lots of people
have trips booked to Asia and Europe and
Iran it's hard to know whether to go or
to cancel what would you tell your
family I think it's extremely important
for people to remain up-to-date on what
the current travel advisories are and
what the current travel warnings are
certainly we know Canada has very
publicly made this very widely available
on their websites certainly with the
travel advisories but I think it's
important that people look at their
destination countries as well and any
points of contact along the way toward
their destination the other challenging
feature here is that these might change
with time so it's important that people
stay up-to-date on what these travel
advisories are so washing your hands
coughing into your elbow is great advice
of course but the way this seems to be
spreading is it is there really a
fail-safe way to protect yourself no I
mean there's just things that we can do
to reduce our chances of getting this
infection and I know during influenza
season we have these recommendations and
and and these recommendations still set
stand for the köppen 19 infection we
also just have to remember that Cova 19
is a respiratory infection as well so
you know impeccable hand hygiene is
crucial coughing and sneezing into your
arm rather than into the air around your
into your hands is also important and of
course if people are sick stay home so
you don't infect anyone else at work or
at school
yeah staying home probably the best
advice we know that most people who get
this virus do survive and it's important
to keep saying that but we've been told
to prepare for this to disrupt our lives
what do you think that means in
practical terms for most people well
it's it's not yet clear what the impact
of this will be in Canada certainly we
know that there's going to be more cases
either imported cases from other parts
of the world and even the potential for
locally acquired cases as well of course
as you point out most people that get
this infection are
probably gonna do just fine and have a
mild course of infection but yeah some
people are gonna get pretty sick so I
think it's just important to be aware
that over the next few weeks to months
we'll likely to we're likely to see more
and more cases of this and to be
prepared I mean if people have chronic
medical conditions now is the time to go
to your primary care provider or
specialist and ensure that you're
up-to-date on all your prescriptions
up-to-date on your vaccinations
up-to-date on ensuring that your health
is optimized before we start to see more
of these cases here in Canada quick
final question based on what you know so
far do you think this virus can be
contained no I don't think it can be
contained certainly the massive Public
Health Initiatives in China slowed the
spread of this virus down and it really
bought the world a few weeks to maybe a
few months to to prepare for this
hopefully governments and healthcare
systems really use that time wisely and
scaled up capacity at at the laboratory
level and at the clinical level to
prepare for the inevitable imported
cases that they're going to be seeing
over the next few weeks to months to
come all right dr. Isaac BOE gosh in
Toronto thanks and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Frieden it's pink shirt day and in honor
of that we leave you with this
a show of support for the anti-bullying
campaign drew crowds and smiles in
downtown Vancouver today the theme of
pink shirt they this year is to lift
each other up give it a try and thanks
for watching
bye bye
[Music]